donald trump has defeated ron desantis  in the turning point usa straw poll this  is important because this is an event  the turning point usa event over the  weekend that took place in florida where  ron desantis is currently the governor  so right now there is no clear set of  data about whether the republican party  is ultimately going to go trump or  desantis in 24 assuming that they both  run there are some polls in which trump  looks very strong there are some polls  in which trump looks very weak and  desantis looks very good it's too early  to say many things have to fall into  place is joe biden running for  reelection do republicans win in the  midterms all sorts of things that have  to be sorted out but what the polling  does show us is it's going to be a fight  who do you think prevails let me know in  a comment trump or desantis if they both  run